the Joe Rogan experience we are a couple
a couple weeks ago I saw you The Comedy
Store and you asked me about your boy
Brendan yeah and like you you would ask
me about you you let's explain the whole
thing to people that don't know the
story
Brendan said something where he was
talking about UFC tonight right COC
tonight yeah well he's talking about the
Fox and the Fox Fox panel and he said
something about I get it
Fox you're not racist like saying that
you have a bunch of black people on it
yeah yes yeah and because they're not
racist myself tyrant and Sharon Bryant
with the three that were on the desk
that day but also a lot of times were
shot a lot of times DC yeah and so it
was like I but are you checking off
boxes because are these the best brains
and the best speakers for the job right
and it was like and you know I some
people see the point that he was trying
to make the point that he claims that he
was trying to make but the thing is when
you when you start when you start in on
this race thing you're saying
effectively that these there's a person
or a group of these people are only
there because of the color of their skin
right
you could you could say all of that
without without the whole I get it
you're not racist you're you checking
off boxes or whatever right because if
that doesn't matter to the question that
or the point that you're trying to make
then why bring it up Brian you know
that's I feel like I know Brendan very
well I love him he's one of my best
friends he's definitely not a racist but
he definitely talks too much
yeah and I don't mean that in a bad way
like he talks too much
I mean like he says he's too many
podcasts and too many things and you say
things and I'm a hundred percent guilty
this you say things and you like well I
don't even say that and then all sudden
you're defending it and then you're
you're caught up in a you know just like
a wave of just trying to sort out what
you're saying without someone being
there to say well look here's thing
tyron woodley UFC welterweight world
champion Eve Edwards
arguably the best 155 are in the world
at one point in time
massive veteran support you can go down
the list Rashad Evans former light
heavyweight champion I mean you're
talking about
top-flight champions former champions
elite mixed martial artists but you also
have Bisping y'all said Paul Felder you
also have Kenny yeah Kenny Florian
you know you have just they're just
elite top of the food chain fighters and
analysts I think it was a bad path to go
down I don't think it made sense I just
I think he thought it made sense in his
head when he was saying it I think maybe
he was trying to be controversial maybe
just I don't know you know it didn't
make sense to me yeah it didn't make
sense to me either but like my thing
about it wasn't okay you're being racist
right like it's it's a thing when you
bring race into the fit to the situation
- right but my thing wasn't your racist
because you say this my thing was you're
saying that I'm in this position because
I'm not good enough right you're saying
that I'm only here because of
affirmative action or whatever you want
to call it you know there's not a
quality to my work and that's where I'm
like yeah [ __ ] that that's that's not
the case I know I know that I'm good I
know that I'm good at the sport I
understand the sport and I'm good at
explaining what I see Brian who would
you know the other thing is like who
would replace them as we deserve white
people that are missing out yeah I'm the
gig yeah everybody everybody went to an
audition
yeah who's not getting the job though is
there like someone who's like wow this
guy really speaks really well but
they're holding him down because he's
white has that even happened yeah some
people that probably like that to happen
but I don't think that's actually
happened yeah I agree completely but so
we kind of we kind of went through that
you know I um he sent me a message he
apologized about that and I was like
cool like my thing was not about the
race thing my thing was you said these
things and you're either saying somebody
or a group of people up there aren't
qualify for the job you're insinuating
that a group of people that you belong
to right not qualified to the yesö so
that without that's where I was coming
from with it yeah
and then I thought it was squash but
then he said some other stuff after that
and that's where I'm like what do you
say afterwards I'm excused I think I
forget the guys name Luke Luke sorry
I remember Luke Thomas write news on
this guy Luke Thomas's show ah and he's
he's saying stuff he's specifically
talking about me now he's like yeah I
talked to them we're all friends I talk
to eat and he's like well see Eve
there's something Eve seasoned himself
and I'm just like man you're not you
know but he said yeah like he said I
feel like that's something Eve seasoned
himself he was aggressive and they say
you know he said he said he was um he
was emotional and that's not I'm like
like there's an I never said to you I
was emotional none of these things so
like you're like this bus is coming
you're waiting to throw me in front of
it or some [ __ ] like that and I'm like
yeah no that's not cool man like we're
not friends we know each other the
extent of our friendship is like a UFC
last summer I saw it Brennan across the
aisle and some guy rolled up on him and
stalking him for like 10 minutes and I'm
looking back and I could see Brendan's
like [ __ ] like I'm like let me let me go
try and help him out so I go over there
and I start talking to Brendan and then
the dude just hangs out I talk to Rendon
for about 5-10 minutes and then the dude
just hanging out behind us and I'm just
like that's all I got man I'm going back
to my seat that's the extent of it I've
seen him at different places beyond that
you know Brian and I are cool so I've
seen him some times when I seen Brian
but like we're not boys we don't know
each other like that's and like she and
you're not a psychologist you're not a
psychiatrist so you're not qualified to
be speaking on my mentals I didn't know
that he said that I feel like now that
I'm remembering it you might have
brought that up at the Comedy Store the
other night it didn't make any sense it
doesn't make it ended friend and I can't
defend him on that because it doesn't
make any sense it just didn't it doesn't
make any sense yeah but sometimes he
says she had that doesn't make sense and
maybe if you were in the room with him
he wouldn't have said it
or maybe he would have said it better or
maybe he would have you know said are
these really the best minds
[Applause]